the Eastern Cape Province of South
Africa is home to the cosa people one of
the nation's largest tribes the Cosa
live in the modern world but they
maintain ancient customs including one
by which boys become men it's a rite of
passage that starts with pain every
summer boys are circumcised painted
white and isolated and remote Hut's
where they spend weeks healing always a
difficult and dangerous experience the
tradition has become even more so here
in the city initiates crowd into all
available space hygiene is poor and
infection is common some cosa boys die
trying to become men
[Applause]
the Mahal a family is sending one of its
own the journey to manhood Tondo is
enjoying his last day as a boy and what
do you about appeal and everybody like
is something he's not clean so weird
because I hear lot of guys go to
hospital the whole poster community will
participate in this rite of passage the
men load up materials to build tanto a
hut in the bush
[Applause]
his family chose an isolated site at the
outskirts of town distracted by the Hut
constructions Kondo doesn't notice that
the surgeon has arrived
traditional surgeons have no formal
training but some have more skill than
others there will be no ceremony before
the circumcision it comes with the speed
of an amble without warning the surgeon
steps forward to remove Hondo's foreskin
ignoring the pain Tondo shouts out cosa
tradition holds that foreskin is must be
buried to keep sorcerers from using them
in witchcraft the surgeon is also
careful to clean the blade to reduce the
risk of transmitting diseases such as
AIDS when the hut is read he'll be left
here alone for weeks now the real danger
ratandas initiation begins in the coming
weeks he faces the risk of infection
even gangrene and until he's healed he
can eat no fresh food and drink no water
- Lala Salama the initiates must not
drink water because the water comes out
of the penis and makes the wound wet so
it doesn't heal properly should
infection strike he'll have to choose
between getting care and remaining true
to his tribe if he seeks medical
attention the Cosa will never accept him
and
the white clay paint marks Tondo as an
initiate he'll wear it throughout his
transition but right now his mind is on
water which he is forbidden to drink
sometimes initiates face dehydration so
severe it can sicken or even kill Tondo
is allowed to sustain himself with only
a liquid made from corn after a week's
Tondo is well enough to drink water and
he's allowed to visit with other
initiates whose huts are nearby their
experiences here in the bush will bind
them together in the cosas community one
month after Tondo left the men make one
last trip to his Hut gone is the white
clay pain of a boy now tanto undergoes a
centuries-old custom a coating of fat
but instead of the animal fat his
ancestors he's anointed with margarine
from the supermarket the entire
community gathers to celebrate and
return
everyone escorts him home neighbors join
the throng his achievement is there
by respecting tradition and prevailing
over hardship Tondo has proven himself a
man red clay marks his new status he is
now eligible for marriage and other
rights of adulthood he has earned his
place in the Cosa nation
[Music]